I don't know why she won't sleep I mean
she's fed she's got a fresh diaper
she's swaddled maybe because we're
making eye contact
what well I read that if you make eye
contact it keeps them engaged and awake
she asleep I don't know I can't see her
what is that this is a glove full of
beans you lay it on their back in it you
know makes products I miss touching them
while they're sleeping okay where did
you hear about that and don't say the
internet let's go
there was a farmer who had a dog and
bingo was his name ARF
I enjoy f ing Oh ARF
hi NGO bingo was his name-o there was a
farmer had a dog and bingo was his
name-o
arf arf oh oh I've have life oh and
bingo was his name-o was a dog and
picklepuss is Dane hello Bea I ng oh she
asleep yet nope
how about now no yeah no I don't get it
I mean I guess let's just let her stay
up no I think I have one last thing what
are you doing I read that if you do this
that they will be asleep in less than a
minute okay we're trying to get her to
go to sleep not teaser like a southern
belle ah I stand corrected
but that's our bed yeah there was a
farmer had a dog and bingo was his knee